welcome king james
i'm a cartoon i'm shorter than kevin
hart
[Music]
um what's up doc bugs bring it here man
what brings you to tonwa doc the
computer dude kidnapped my son
what in the matrix hell
hey what'd you do to my son the only way
you're getting your son back is if you
and i play a little basketball you want
to play me in basketball
i need to assemble an elite team
i'll take it from here sam shoot the
ball
let's try that again shall we we'll get
your son back
i promise what's happening
i look expensive introducing
the goon squad
i got it i got it
she got me i'm not a betting duck but my
money's on the other team
of the gym your king
you're about to lose your family in my
head
everything you love well at least we're
good
oh and i almost forgot all of the tunes
will be deleted so
come on guys the toon squad doesn't give
up if we're going out
we're going out looney
you gotta win this game and get our son
back
pump up the chance let's go twos i got
hops
it's on coming off the bench
widely coyote the machine is
producing multiple riley coyotes
well that happened wow
we need a boost a secret weapon come on
man granny's out here having a martini
at halftime kate is gonna hate